Charlie day who's been known on TV small
screen It's Always Sunny in Philadelphia
and on the big screen Horrible Bosses
and coming up on June the 8th Hotel
Artemis good to see you Charlie day good
to be here and then on the small screen
Modern Family we'll just like our
previous oh worker of course caught
workaholics on Comedy Central and game
over man
streaming last couple of months on
Netflix and in films like football
players cannot get enough of pitch
perfect good to see you Adam Devine good
to see it's like pitch perfect a lot I'm
I'm not kidding
that is I mean you saw obviously I mean
future versions of pitch perfect news
and that's that would be something I
would participate myself but the Packers
wanted in like the Packers asked in yeah
they requested to be in the second one
and that's how movies work i'ma tell ya
he's pretty damn good belcheck knows all
the song it's imperfect you see what I
did that's right
that was good as I appreciate you gave
me a little bit of a head nod there on
that I got it yeah I appreciate that one
thank you very much
all day long you're not pretending any
area exactly I appreciate that
which are you a football fan you have
any any specific sport that you are
partial to it I'm more partial to
baseball okay and I'm kind of a nut for
golf okay
do you play yourself do you play what's
your what's your game like I'm a five
are you serious yeah you break you break
80 every time out pretty much pretty
much not every time but that's how it
works yeah a couple really low rounds
and then a couple over 80 when you first
pick up a stick uh I got really into it
like a decade ago and like I'm a junkie
for it like I took a bunch of lessons
and I'm always okay tinkering all right
so who's your favorite player I mean who
growing up were you always I mean
there's so many good guys now like you
know if Spieth gets that putter out
again I like to watch him win a little
bit more look I want Tiger to stay
healthy
and perform you know I'd like to see him
break the records yeah I know where I'm
always where any time he shows up and
has anything remotely close to what he
used to be yeah we think that it's it's
going to he's bad we're like same age so
I feel like peers you know well you are
as buds you what you are known as the
the Tiger Woods of of comedy in a way
that's really that's that's a fact you
know that's that's why I don't have it
on my card here and the John Daly of
comedy yeah you know John Daly I am he
has been on the show back in our Los
Angeles studio and I have said and these
guys over there will attest to this and
they think I'm crazy I think this is
nuts
I would I would let him hit a tee ball
off a tee that I am holding in my mouth
I'll tell you why that's crazy and his
launches his alcoholism it's why why
bother
well I don't know how it came up I don't
know the conversation I think no we saw
we saw video of him doing that off a
beer can that a member of the gallery
was whole was holding on his chin okay
and I said I would let him do because
doesn't like I'm crazy a little bit here
no I want to see it I'm looking at okay
like why haven't you done it because
what if the what if this one time he's
like you know what I don't like this guy
you know what rich you know what rich
this is a real dumb move Craig well how
do you think you could do that Charlie
as a as a I wouldn't a stick golf I'm a
decent cover but I would not trust
myself to hit I think I could do it I
think it proud of what I hate your face
but I wouldn't want to try let's get the
club out all right I wish we had one of
our Callaway the driver that's risky see
but I mean but you you're you're five so
that might be the one time where you
know the hips move a little bit too soon
and you're gaining confidence
[Laughter]
fantastic Charlie Day and Adam Devine
here Adam I have seen you in a couple of
clipper games I've seen a lot are you a
clipper season ticket holder or half
season tickets why the Clippers ah I
couldn't afford the Lakers that that is
true that was like when I first started
to go to games I couldn't afford good
Laker tickets right but for $7 this is
like 10 years ago you could get clipper
tickets and then walk down to the court
because no one was there and they were
just like please we're on TV and no
one's in the stands and then as soon as
I started to make any amount of money
the Clippers got good and then it kind
of kind of worked out that way
so I'm going to and so we're winning the
championship next year I'm going to if
you don't mind put you on the spot here
Adam I'm gonna put you on the spot
please please I'm gonna give you the the
platform here oh thank you to address
LeBron James who may or may not be out
there and pitch him on why he should
choose the Clippers over the Lakers this
summer well for his legacy if he goes to
the Lakers that there's too many
superstars there he'll be one of many
people then it'll be a conversation of
him or magic you know but if he goes to
the Clippers he immediately will be the
greatest Clipper of all time hands-down
guaranteed and to turn that franchise
and give them around and give them their
first LeBron please come to the club I
just start crying please come
well--that's by the way you're not wrong
yeah I mean like nobody's gonna say
LeBron or all the candy you know I mean
so right and and and cuz when you go to
a clipper game they cover up the Laker
banners with just photographs of current
members then there's no there's no
retired is nothing now there's zero
retired he would create his own legacy
that yeah I would that we would retire
him before he's retired come here we're
putting your jersey right and the mm-hmm
we're hanging it sugar before I let you
go because Rudd and Saberhagen are going
to be here
and to close out the show what sort of
softball game are we gonna see from
either one of you tonight well you said
we are the bash brothers yo yeah I mean
I wanna put one in the fountain if I can
I don't know if I get a good breeze in
my back well I mean you say that you're
a 5 handicap you should be able to
translate yeah I mean you got a the
balls been moving at me you guys pop it
on a tee I'm gonna rope it Manny I don't
think that's gonna happen tonight I'm
just looking to get it out of the
infield okay that's that's my big hope
this afternoon all right well Charlie I
and I don't appreciate you guys coming
here Hotel Artemis in theaters next week
June 8th jodie foster's on our show next
week in Los Angeles studio Sarah is
there any anything I should know about
beforehand I mean which he looks better
this way would she be fine if I served
her fava beans with a nice Chianti would
she find that funny or what I should I
avoid that sort of thing with I'd like
to see you try it yeah the same with
like which one would be more dangerous
for me to attempt John Daly hitting a
golf ball out of a tee held in my mapa
beans for sure so she's got so she's in
the hotel Artemis and that's for seeing
that and Adam you've got the package
available for streaming and Netflix
coming up later on this summer
yep that's right ok that's streaming on
Netflix on August 10 look forward to
hanging out with you guys throughout the
week cool thanks for being great Adam
Devine and Charlie Day right here Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience